Jenna Ortega fans are you going to see
Miller's girl Jenna Ortega's upcoming
movie has sparked controversy due to the
teacher student relationship at the
center of the plot but movies that spark
controversy are Ortega's favorite
projects so it seems that this it girl
is perfect for the thought-provoking
role while it may be a bit different
from her other roles her deadpan comedic
style and Love of All Things spooky will
be at play Let's talk about why no one
could be Miller's girl quite like Jenna
oraga Jenna is is certainly an IT girl
these days and we've all come to know
her signature style it's clear that
she's bringing that style to her
character in Miller's girl what's your
name CYO sweet while this role is
different for her we can tell from the
trailers that Ortega will be bringing
her typical dead pan sensibilities to
the role of Cairo site rap Miller's girl
uh beginning of October and while this
project may have sparked a lot of
controversy it's clear that it was
important to her I'm really curious to
see how that one turns out uh just
because it's is probably the most
complex character that I've ever played
so while some may have been surprised
that Ortega was involved in such a risky
role it turns out that this is exactly
the kind of character she's most
interested in playing at the moment I
always think it's interesting to do
films that make people uncomfortable so
I cared a lot about that one from the
scream franchise to Netflix is you and
of course taking over the role of
Wednesday Adams in Wednesday Jenna Orga
is thought of as this generation's
scream Queen while Miller's girl may be
a bit different than her usual type of
Thriller it still fits in with Ora's
flare for the spooky perfectly don't you
get scared walking through those wood
I'm the scariest thing in there and by
the sounds of it this star has no
problem with the scream Queen title I
love and horror is horror is home Ortega
is a major fan of the genre that she
calls home but she's also got a theory
about why the public has welcomed her as
the face of that genre people really
like to see me hysterical I wouldn't
even say I have a good screen but it's
just very distinctive and I think I have
a really ugly crying face which people
just beat on Orga may be known for being
both scared and scary on screen these
days but when she first started acting
long ago she was anything but scary her
first gig was a toothpaste commercial
when she was just 9 years old she became
better known in the Disney Channel
series stuck in the middle and it's
common for Disney stars to struggle with
growing into more mature roles while it
seems natural for Jenna she struggled
just like her peers I tend to do younger
roles so I was also doing children
oriented work which I think breaking out
of that is its own Challenge and journey
in itself but breaking out of it she did
and she's happy to have gotten to where
she is I did a movie a couple of years
ago where it was a horror film and I
went from like super Conservative
Christian girl turned adult film star
that was a bit of a turning point Ortega
also thinks she's had plenty of fans
who've been along for the wild ride of
her career with her in an interview with
Entertainment Tonight Ortega said of her
fans fortunately they've kind of grown
up with me so I think that they're at an
age where I think they'll be able to
respect maybe some of the jokes and
references we make even though Jenna
Ortega loves a movie that makes people
uncomfortable it couldn't be easy to
embody her Miller's girl character
luckily she and Cairo sweet have some
things in common you talked about not
being able to care for a house PL but
spoke very reverently about protecting
your 1897 edition of Ralph Waldo Emerson
essays literature is important to ortaga
which is also true for Miller's girl
character those are incredible I I wish
that people would read them more we need
real substance like go outside and read
a book yes Cairo sweet would agree I
read the whole list there's 12 books on
that list partyart Ortega may be a big
reader but her Ralph Waldo Emerson
collection holds a special place in her
heart because she's a writer too just
like her character I don't write a lot
of screenplays but I do like to write a
lot of essays someone like Emerson a lot
of his work is essays even though she
and her character have plenty in common
Ortega also had to get into the spooky
aspects of playing Cairo somehow though
she makes it look easy and you were in a
fridge another time you were balancing
tortillas on your head you try to keep
it light and fun in between takes now I
actually do stuff like that to scare
myself feel like in the fridge it's
really isolating as soon as the door is
closed and it's dark in there Mara's
pranks are fun for her castmates and
great for getting into character it's a
moment of resetting right before a take
so there's no distractions no anything
it's just you with your thoughts and you
get the time to really amp yourself up
whatever method she used certainly works
and just one look at her at the movies
Premiere made it clear that she's
totally in her element with this film so
are you excited to see Jenna Ortega in
Miller's girl are you glad she took on
this role let's discuss it in the
comments and for more videos about your
favorite stars like And subscribe to the
things